there is something happening because
it's not just aoc that is turning
unbidet and youth culture is turning on
biden and the democrats and and trudeau
and all these things young people are
waking up which of course is always why
the threat of censorship just sits there
because the more people wake up the more
they have to clamp down on people who
are thinking freely who are thinking
things through for themselves who are
you know flickering that that light the
neurons are firing again they're
swallowing that red pill so you know
this jake paul guy he's got 20 million
subs on youtube he's got 4.3 million
followers on twitter he's huge for the
young people i'm not exactly sure what
he does he does like prank videos and he
occasionally fights people or something
he's big the point is it doesn't matter
whether i know anything about the guy or
not he's big with the kids well he
tweeted this out just in the last day or
two biden accomplishments highest gas
prices worst inflation plummeting crypto
prices highest rent prices ever created
new incomprehensible language
if you're reading this and voted for
biden and you still don't regret it then
you were the american problem that got
122.5
000
likes okay
this is big it doesn't matter if you
watching this know this guy or not he's
big within young people the fact that
young people are now waking up to this
insanity realizing that things were
pretty good
under trump they were damn good under
trump uh he
this is the point this guy was he was a
holly he was like a disney actor right
is that where that's what started this
guy like something is actually happening
here but what are they gonna have to do
now you know where i'm going with this
when people start waking up what do they
have to do they have to censor you or
there's the other option that they have
which is scare the flying bejesus out of
you and what might the gop do or not do
with their newly claimed power
so the january 6 uh commission would
cease to exist
uh the findings will be completely
suppressed and will not be
admitted into any for further uh
investigations while the gop
will be in power uh they would impres um
they would um impeach president biden um
as quickly as possible and they will
continue to continue to find ways uh to
impeach him going forward it would also
embolden
republicans and the far right and white
nationalists across the country to begin
to believe that it is their time to not
just take power in the house but the
senate the white house and state houses
across the country
and we got to understand that this is a
group that has been radicalized by the
great replacement myth and many other
things and have been pushing for
violence and pushing for even civil
war
you see what they're gonna do they're
telling you what they're gonna do and
when people tell you what they're gonna
do when people tell you what they really
think you should believe them so they're
prepping their own audience because
they're going if we can't censor
everybody and we are going to get
crushed in the midterms which is what it
looks like we better get everyone as
fearful as possible because the white
nationalists might launch a civil war
yeah
it's such crazy nonsense by the way that
guy that guy he's a he's a new york
congressman that's not just one of their
generic like msnbc contributor lunatics
he's a new york congressman and if the
republicans retake congress they're
going to impeach biden well they might
and he probably should be impeached
because he doesn't have the mental
capacity to be president you guys also
ran two fake impeachments but that white
nationalists are coming they're coming
and the civil war is here and again guys
that's why i always say what do we do
with these people we can't turn these
people around i can't turn around the
truly uh
kool-aid drunk people of msnbc but we
can separate from them and i don't mean
that in a violent civil war i mean that
from build new things and let them let
them have some stuff and let them
destroy themselves and we'll go on and
live better lives